this is tumor hussein reading for
reviewer richard wakeling no more heroes
3 asks the question what if et came back
to earth 20 years after leaving and was
an insufferable [ __ ] it's the kind of
offbeat set up for a video game you
would expect from the unorthodox minds
of developer grasshopper games and game
directed sudo 51 and this basic premise
contributes to what is a strong opening
for normal heroes 3. between its ae's
anime-inspired opening your first taste
of travis touchdown's cathartic combat
plenty of callbacks and a suitably
inventive first boss fight it makes it
all the more surprising when this
initial goodwill is gradually chipped
away but don't you worry a hero descends
what there are no heroes in this world
oh but there totally are
my name is travis touchdown i'm the last
hero around here to save the world i'm
also just a passing assassin
here we go
the first two games in this series were
rough around the edges but that was part
of their charm they were scrappy and
stylish both revered and derived with a
punk rock spirit that made them cult
classics no more heroes 3 is zany and
maintains those coarse elements but i
also feel forced in a how do you do
fellow kids kinda way you still have to
go to the toilet to save your game and
jerk off to recharge travis's beam
katana so the juvenile humour remains
intact it just isn't very funny not
because the jokes aren't landing but
because there aren't many to speak of
most of the story revolves around
returning alien foo an intolerable
antagonist who's prone to random
outbursts of violence there isn't much
more to the character than that and the
conversations he has with his cronies
are plodding and shallow with dialogue
that's often about nothing in particular
and not in a good seinfeld kind of way
either normal hero 3 still has a habit
of breaking down the fourth wall to
provide knowing commentary on video
games and gamer culture and there are
plenty of self-deprecating lines and
over references to the likes of x-files
terminator akira and rocky but these are
flimsy band-aids on a narrative that's
disappointingly tedious the same can
also be said of its overall structure no
more heroes 3 reverts back to the first
games framework by giving you an open
world to explore in between each boss
battle there's nothing inherently wrong
with this design and the familiar
ranking setup is still synonymous with
the series for good reason as is
customary travis begins at the bottom of
the rankings and must murder his way up
to the number one spot in this case the
united assassination association has
devised the galactic superhero rankings
with members of foo's galactic superhero
corps occupying all 10 places you still
need to pay a fee to enter the uaa
before attempting each fight so
completing activities to procure enough
cash quickly becomes the perpetual
routine herein lies the problem in order
to progress you have to complete three
designated matches these are confined
combat scenarios where you're teleported
to a location and must defeat three or
four enemies to progress in most cases
this will earn you enough money to pay
the uaa's entry fee and proceed to the
next boss battle the only time this
changes is towards the end of the game
when you need to earn a little more cash
but this comes across as unnecessary
padding there are also optional wave
based combat challenges to partake in
and the menial side jobs from the first
game return if you fancy mowing grass or
picking up trash
[Applause]
across the series these mini games are
never particularly fun but that's the
whole point if you don't like doing
these mundane and repetitive tasks
they're at least backed up by an idea
travis's quest to become the top-ranked
assassin means occasionally working odd
jobs to pay the bills but that idea
doesn't really work in normal heroes 3
considering the world ending stakes the
fact that sound to destroy is now
populated by aliens and that you never
really need the extra cash it feels like
mini games are included just because
that's no more heroes thing not just
because they're a satirical take on open
world game design or the realities of
life the other issue with these sections
is that they lack the charm and
personality of the first game in the
original normal heroes working those
part-time jobs meant visiting the job
center beforehand and levelling up
required you to build up a sweat at
ryan's gym naomi's lab was also there
for all your beam container upgrade
needs and you could even visit beefhead
to purchase pro wrestling videotapes and
learn new moves in normal hero 3 all of
this is reduced to an upgrade system
that you dump points into this is more
efficient but it makes the baron open
world feel even more empty and
meaningless than it already is even
combat feels disconnected from
everything else since you're nearly
always transported to bespoke
extraterrestrial arenas you don't even
have to fight your way through mobs to
reach each boss battle most of the time
you're taken right to the front door
despite its disconnect from the rest of
the game combat is no more heroes 3's
saving grace it loses some of the depth
from previous games since you don't have
to worry about low or high attacks or
swapping between multiple beam katanas
but it makes up for it in other areas
you've got your usual repertoire of
light and heavy attacks plus you can
block and perform perfect dodges to slow
down time giving you ample opportunity
to deal plenty of damage jumping attacks
are a new addition and travis's death
glove gives you access to 4 dynamic
skill moves including a flying death
kick and an area of effect attack by
wailing on enemies enough times in
succession to make them see stars you
can also unleash a torrent of pro
wrestling moves this will instantly
recharge the beam katana allowing you to
carry on fighting and potentially rack
up 200 hit combos
[Music]
there's a decent rogues gallery of enemy
types too each with their own unique
attacks and defenses the leopardon for
instance uses giant eggs to teleport
away from you where it can use this
ranged weapon to disable the death
gloves fighting multiple enemy types at
once forces you to adapt and utilize
every tool in your arsenal resulting in
some of the most engaging battles
there's a lack of indicators for enemies
melee attacks so it can be frustrating
when you're unsuspectingly hit from
behind but the heft and sensor of
momentum behind travis's attacks makes
combat particularly pleasing especially
when you're able to mix in some german
suplexes to extend that combo it doesn't
really evolve all that much throughout
the course of the game but it speaks to
the quality of its action that it never
loses its satisfying luster it also
helps that the frame rate maintains a
fairly stable 60 frames per second both
docked and undocked on switch the same
cannot be said during the open world
sections but it also isn't required to
navigate its desolate locales boss
fights will challenge your skill set
more than anything else although their
quality is decidedly inconsistent at
best they elevate the combat with
surprising new twists and energetic
impetus in the ninth ranked fight
against gold joel for instance you can
use his magnetism against him by running
over either the red or blue squares that
appear on the floor you can match those
polarity and push him into the
electrified fence that's surrounding the
arena however some of the boss fights
deviate from the game's traditional
combat in order to riff on other games
and genres these sections are often poor
implementations of better games that
quickly lose their intrigue after the
initial surprise reveal the final boss
is particularly bad as the last
confrontation devolves into a monotonous
slog that forces you to wait and wait
and wait until a small window of
opportunity opens up where you can
finally dish out a modicum of damage and
then when you think it's all over it
transitions into another phase that's
somehow even duller if you had a mandate
for all the things a normal hero's game
shouldn't be boring would be near the
top of the list but this sequel is
frequently just that normal hero 3 lacks
the irreverent charm and personality of
his predecessors combat picks up the
slack and there's a degree of vivid
style to be found there but the game
falters in so many other areas after an
11 year wait maybe normal heroes 3 was
always destined to fall short of our
expectations but to end without so much
as a touchdown is a mighty
disappointment
hey gamers
limit your gaming to 10 hours per day
anymore and you're seriously gonna die
gamers have but one goal
to take down the opponent in front of
you
hurry up and grab the controller the
game has already started